sup everyone jordan here with gamespot's
first preview of first spoken before we
get started we'd appreciate if you'd
subscribe to the channel and be sure to
leave us a like if you enjoy the video
now my first impression of first spoken
when i saw that first announcement
trailer was genuine glee seeing a
japanese developed role-playing game
with a dark-skinned person of color as
the main protagonist is rare seeing such
a game starring a black woman is
exceptionally rare learning later that a
vast majority of the principal cast or
woman is practically unheard of so i
went into this latest hands-off preview
of first spoken with hopeful
expectations and at first it seemed like
developer luminous productions and
publisher square enix knew their stuff
going into this game for spoken creative
producer ryo mitsuno wanted this to be
an experience that primarily featured a
female cast and start a protagonist that
broke free of conventional fantasy hero
tropes everything else about the game
was built around that concept from the
beginning of the project in an interview
mitsuno told gamespot quote that was
really one of the core concepts that we
had from the very beginning of the game
we wanted to create a world with a bunch
of strong female characters and we
wanted a world of magic and we wanted to
use those as our pillars when we started
the project we were impressed with the
increasing number of female leads in the
industry but we wanted to really take it
a step further and go with a
female-centric world we also wanted with
our main character frey to portray a
character who was really down to earth
and realistic portrayal of a modern day
young woman who just so happens to then
get thrown into this world with a bunch
of powerful woman a sort of matriarchal
society end quote
and for spoken you play as frey holland
a young new yorker who has hit rock
bottom in her life and desperately
yearns to get out of the city and find a
place where she can belong she sort of
gets her wish when a strange portal
suddenly transports her to the
fantastical world of atheia where she
meets a sentient bracelet named cuff she
eventually befriends the people of the
last surviving human city on atheia
which is only spared by the growing
miasma called the break blanketing the
land by existing on a mountaintop frey
sets off in search of a way home
learning she's capable of extremely
powerful magic along the way which aids
around both traversal and combat it's a
setup that reminds me a lot of isekai a
japanese genre of light novels manga
anime and games where the protagonist is
transported to and becomes trapped in
another world less so modern-day isekai
which are largely harem focused male
power fantasies and more so 90s and
early 2000s isakai where female
protagonists and mixed gendered hero
groups dominated the genre and the
stories focused on achieving personal
power and agency by finding
self-confidence and overcoming doubts
and insecurities those are vibes that i
find intriguing but i'm worried about
how well the game can capture the
experience of a black woman in that
storyline in terms of writing talent the
studio has that on lock both rogue one
co-writer gary wida and uncharted 1 2
and 3 head writer and creative director
amy hennig created the bedrock for first
spoken story with what are responsible
for developing the concept of the world
and henrik focusing on the narrative and
how it fit into the design of the game
from there writing the final story and
script was handed over to lead writers
todd stashwick and alison reimer the
issue that gives me pause is that none
of those people are black so as good as
the story may be the preview left me
with misgivings about the writing for
its protagonists in response luminous
productions development team told
gamespot over email that writers and
voice talent were both instrumental in
the development of frey's character
writing quote we worked closely with a
number of consultants from bipoc
backgrounds to help portray frey's
character and tell the story from her
perspective end quote all in all it
sounds like the team has done the
homework but i'm still a little
concerned over the lack of color in for
spoken's writer's room i will be
thrilled if i see i'm worrying about
nothing once for spoken launches but for
now i'm remaining cautious for those
curious as to whether for spoken's
gameplay is any fun i'm not sure what to
tell you previews only ever give us a
small sample of what a game is and it's
even harder to make a judgment call when
you're only watching a recording of
someone else playing and can't even get
a sense of how it all feels is zipping
through the environment with a flurry of
parkour moves as satisfying as it looks
maybe are the variety of spell
combinations you can pull off as
rewarding to do as they appear
gosh i hope so i can say that my first
impression of the world of atheism mixed
the act of exploring looks fun with how
quickly and efficiently fray flips and
hops through the environment like a
magical spider woman movement is stylish
and fluid with the world speeding past
you a seemingly gratifying pace and frey
appears to possess abilities that will
allow her to navigate athy on both
horizontal and vertical planes which
means there could be a nice verticality
to combat as well but the world itself
seems empty of meaningful things to go
find and do beyond fighting different
enemies in a statement luminous
productions wrote that quote there are
still plenty of things for players to
discover organically if they venture off
the beaten path end quote
but i saw no clear example of that
during the presentation if the preview
is any indication it sounds like the
main crux of what players will
experience when exploring the open world
is near constant chatter between frey
and cuff other open world games have
used banter between their characters to
fill the void and quiet space while
exploring between story missions saints
row 4 sunset overdrive marvel spider-man
and death loop just to name a few but
i'm still worried by just how empty
atheia looks banter and enjoyable
movement can only propel an open world
so far i think the idea of a single city
being the last safe haven sounds cool on
paper but in practice it results in a
world that looks devoid of life as soon
as you leave the one hub area
admittedly this does create a narrative
development that i am intrigued to see
unfold in for spoken story athea is so
devoid of life because the break
transforms every living thing that comes
in contact with it into a terrifying
monster regardless of what that creature
was originally so frey's ability to
safely move within the break puts her at
odds with everyone else they view her as
a demon who's not to be trusted
ironically her ability to navigate the
break means she's also the only person
ideally suited to exploring it finding
its root cause and stopping it so
alongside her quest to get home frey is
also roped into aiding people who don't
want anything to do with her
i didn't get a chance to see how that
dynamic could play out but at least
sounds intriguing as it sets up the
world of atheia where freya is outwardly
attacked by monsters whenever she
ventures outside the city and mentally
and emotionally attacked by societal
stigma when within the city those are
two totally different conflicts for the
game to possibly explore and if it does
i wonder which of the two will fray
handle better all in all for spoken
looks like a pretty game it looks like
an experience where navigation and
combat mechanics flow together and
you're able to pull off bombastic combos
with seemingly hard-hitting attacks that
explode with a display of colorful
carnage for spoken looks like a game
where you return to a hub city and
regularly venture out into a world that
appears to be shockingly devoid of
anything meaningful to do but flip
through the air and fight enemies
problem is i've seen all those things
come together in a game before and
bioware's anthem didn't turn out so well
i'm hoping i'm wrong and that phrase
characterization propels for spoken's
campaign forward but it's hard to tell
how this game will play and whether it's
good without actually getting hands on
with it we're still a ways from that too
as for spoken as planned to launch for
ps5 and pc on may 24th but in the
meantime you can stay up to date on for
spoken and other upcoming rpgs by
subscribing to gamespot if you want to
see more previews like this be sure to
like the video let us know in the
comments if you're a fan of us including
developer quotes in these types of video
previews too and whether we should be
doing that more often
you